Ja, komm.
Schönen guten Tag.
Vielleicht ist mein Name ich bin Züchter in der Arsperie.
Bevor wir jetzt hier nach Berlin beschwerden, kommen wir mit ihr.
Ich habe einige Persönliche da. Wie heißt es ihr?
Mein Name ist Peter Schmidt.
Peter Schmidt. Mit DT am Ende.
Genau.
Wie heißt es ihr?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1.3.1957.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich bin 1,80 m groß.
Und wie geaktuell 75 kg.
85 kg.
Danke für die Informationen Herr Schmidt.
Ich bin 1,80 m groß und wiege 75 kg.
Was wird Sie heute tun?
Ich komme mal zu Ihnen, weil ich immer wieder krank werde.
Ich bin seit mehreren Wochen jetzt und das unruhigt mich.
Ich habe einen Husten, den ich nicht wegbekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich so als krank werde.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Anfälligkeit?
Ich habe mich schon seit ein paar Wochen in der Arsperie.
Nun Jung ist die Anfälligkeit.
Ich wüsste schon sehr lange.
Aber der Husten geht nie weg,also seit mindestens 4 bis 5 Monaten jetzt.
Auch manchmal Schleim?
Ich lebe viele Monate 17 Monats.
Wenn ihr sehr stark rauskommt, dann ist es noch gut raus.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum ich immer wieder krank werde.
Mein Haushalt hat mir schon Antibiotikum gegeben.
Ich habe schon alles Mögliche gemacht, aber irgendwie geht das nicht weg.
Wann haben Sie Antibiotikum eingenommen?
Ich habe mir schon zweimal Antibiotikum genommen.
Also einmal vor ungefähr zwei Monaten und einmal jetzt vor drei Wochen.
Ich habe die Medikamente geholfen.
Ein bisschen, aber das kommt immer wieder.
Das hört ein bisschen, aber dann geht es weiter.
Haben Sie noch weitere Bescheiden?
Schmutz, Kopfschmerzen, Brustschmerzen oder Bauchschmerzen?
Das nicht, aber ich bin schwach geworden wegen diesem Infekt.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fiebrig?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht. Also selten.
Schützen Sie mehr in der Nacht als sonst?
Ja, ich muss auch sehr auf Fuß nennen nach.
Das stelle mich schon sehr an.
Haben Sie viele Schutelfrost?
Nein.
Schmutz, haben Sie irgendwelche im Irmkörper eine Lämpfknotenvergrößerung?
Oder eine Schwellebemmer?
Nein, habe ich nicht mehr.
Haben Sie eine Hautveränderung, z.B. Gelbverbungbemmer?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit? Haben Sie eine Appetitveränderung?
Eigentlich ist es sehr gut.
Ich esse generell nicht so viel.
Aber ich habe jetzt ja keine Beschwerden.
Haben Sie vielleicht in letzter Zeit Ungewollte abgelassen?
Nein, ich nehme das ab.
Ich habe jetzt ungefähr 5 kg abgenommen.
In welche Zeit haben Sie?
Ich habe in den letzten 4 Monaten.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Masalasn oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Haben Sie vielleicht Fahrterender in ihrem Stuhl oder in ihrem Urin?
Nein, auch nicht.
Haben Sie Schlafen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich fühle mich gar nicht gut.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe, bin ich sehr müde, sehr schwach.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum ich immer wieder diese Infekte habe.
Immer wieder bin ich krank.
Haben Sie deswegen bei ihrem Hausarzt vielleicht?
Ja, der hat mir Antibiotikum aufgeschrieben.
Hat er bei Ihnen einen Bluttest oder eine Infekte gemacht?
Ja, der hat es gemacht.
Er sagte, es wäre nicht auffällig, infekt hätte ich wohl.
Er sagte, weißen Blutköppchen wären hoch.
Weißen Blutköppchen?
Bist du wie hoch?
Nein.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Röntgen von ihrem Brustkorb?
Nein, ich habe ihn noch nicht gemacht.
Er sagte, es wäre ein viraler Infekt.
Er hat sogar zweimal gesagt, wir machen trotzdem ein Antibiotikum.
Deswegen habe ich zweimal Antibiotikum bekommen.
Aber irgendwie geht das nicht weg.
Aber Sie haben keine Schmerzen.
Vielleicht haben Sie bei Ihrem Brustkorb.
Wenn ich eine Atme tut, die linke Brust weh.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wegen dem Husten, weil ich so viel huste.
Bei meinem.
Diese Hustenattacken, war der Beginn plötzlich oder langsam?
Können Sie sich erinnern?
Ich habe schon länger morgens huste ich meistens einmal ab.
Wenn ich aufwache, muss ich einmal husten.
Das ist alles gut.
Aber das wird jetzt mal mehr.
Und das ist schon lange.
Gab es einen Auslöser?
Wie meinen Sie Auslöser?
Vor der Hustenattacken haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches gemacht.
Oder wie etwas inhaliert.
Aber etwas in Ihrem Luftröhrer.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Schmin?
Ja, leider ich rauche ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten oder wie lange haben Sie schon?
20, 25 Stück.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Brustschmerzen haben.
Wie würden Sie diese Brustschmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dummstechen?
Ja, ich habe schon 30 Jahre.
Wie viele Zigaretten am Tag?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Sie sind eher dummstechen?
Du stechende Schmerzen.
Wenn ich einen Atmen habe, dann tut es weh.
Und wo habe ich keine Schmerzen?
Okay, verstehe.
Wie viele Brustschmerzen haben Sie?
Ich habe eine Schmerzkalapeone.
Einsteht, wir sehen sehr leichte Schmerzen.
Sie sind jetzt nicht so stark.
Vielleicht 4 oder so.
Hatten Sie vielleicht einen Unfall?
Ob ich einen Unfall gehabt habe?
Jetzt vor Kurzem oder wie?
Vor ungefähr 4 bis 5 Monaten.
Nein, habe ich keine Unfall.
Herr Schmidt gab es Fälle von Krebs
oder einer der Lungen erkrankten in ihrer Familie.
Mutter oder Vater.
Eigentlich nicht.
Warum Sie das Krebs haben?
Sie wissen, ob es eine Krebsfälle in ihrer Familie gibt.
Könnte ich auch Krebs haben?
Jetzt kann ich nichts sagen,
aber für eine Vorsteckanamnese
muss ich daran fragen.
Sie wollen auch mal Eltern Krebs haben?
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Sie sind bei ihren Vater oder Mutter oder Geschirr.
Irgendwelche Kronschehrkrankungen, besonders Krebsfälle.
Krebsfälle haben wir in der Familie.
Okay.
Schmidt, Sie haben beim Ausbruch
Blutbemerk.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie beim Husten manchmal Blutbemerk haben.
Wenn Sie sehr stark Husten mussten,
kommen da schon mal kleine Klümpchen raus.
In welchen Mengen können Sie diese Blut einschätzen?
Oder eine Frischblutung?
Wie meinen Sie Frisch?
Frisch hell blut.
Manchmal.
Aber das kommt, weil ich zu stark Husten bin.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn es die Brunchen wäre.
Hat Ihre Umgebung jemand ähnliche Bescheidung?
Meine Familie?
In Familie oder Umgebung?
Ne.
Sie fragen mich, ob ich eine Umgebung habe.
Sie fragen mich auch schon, warum ich so oft krank werde.
Und warum ich so oft Husten.
Meine Frau macht sich richtig Sorgen.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unfährtheit?
Laktor-Sintoleranz habe ich.
Wie ausert sich diese Laktor-Sintoleranz?
Blähungen, Durchfall, Bauchschmerzen.
Das habe ich nur seit Jahren.
Aber Sie haben keine Allergien?
Nein, das bin ich bekannt.
War Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ich war in Ägypten im Sommer.
Hatten Sie damals irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Da hatte ich auch Husten.
Da habe ich auch erkältet.
Ich möchte einige Fragen wie die Krankheiten.
Sie haben leider keine Krankheiten.
Sie haben ja auch Diabetes.
Ich habe Diabetes.
Und ich habe Blutotruck.
Seitdem haben Sie Diabetes?
Welcher Typ bist du?
Diabetes habe ich schon seit Jugend.
Seitdem ich 18 bin, ist das besser.
Ich bin Sie Insulin?
Ja, Insulin.
Seitdem haben Sie Blutotruck?
Blutotruck habe ich seitdem ich 40 bin.
Haben Sie noch weitere Krankheiten?
Nein, Gott sei Dank.
Ich habe eine Aussage, dass ich erhöhte Cholesterin habe.
Aber der wollte das noch mal kontrollieren.
War das festgestellt?
Ja, der hat das gesehen.
Außer Insulin nehmen Sie noch weitere Medikamente.
Ich habe noch eine Blutdruck.
Was nehmen Sie?
Ich habe eine Kanne Satin und Amlodipine.
Wie viel Milligramm kann das er bekommen?
16 Milligramm, 2 Mal am Tag.
Und Amlodipine wissen Sie?
5 Milligramm, einmal abends.
Herr Schimmit, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich bin bisher nur am Ellenbogen operiert worden.
Wegen einem Unfall?
Nein, da war ein kleiner Geschwulst.
Den haben wir damals rausgenommen, ungefähr 20 Jahre.
Vor 20 Jahren?
Vor 20 Jahren, ja.
Haben Sie noch weitere Operationen?
Nein.
Herr Schimmit, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Leider nicht, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona?
Ich möchte gar nicht mehr den Impfstatus haben.
Ich bin nicht geimpft, nein.
Herr Schimmit, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie rauchen
und trinken Sie auch regelmäßig Alkohol?
Alkohol trink ich selten eigentlich, also nur wenn wir Gäste haben,
vielleicht ein, zweimal im Monat, das will man eine Flasche Wein trinken,
aber nicht viel.
Okay.
Routinemäßig muss ich fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit Trocken haben?
Nein, ich bin zu alt dafür.
Wie gesagt, das ist Routinemäßig eine Frage, Herr Schimmit.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie in Ihrer Familie bei Eltern
keine Krebserkrankungen haben.
Sind bei Ihnen bei Ihrer Eltern noch weitere chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Also ich habe meinen Vater sehr früh verloren, den kannte ich gar nicht so,
da war ich noch jung.
Und meine Mutter ist einem Schlag an den Fall verstorben.
Nein, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Er sei einfach umgefallen, sagte mein.
Er ist einfach plötzlich umgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister, Herr Schimmit?
Ich habe keine Geschwister, nein.
Alle zwei verstorben.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ich habe es zweitgeschwister gehabt, die sind beide verstorben.
Darf ich fragen, woran Sie sind gestorben?
Also die eine hatte tatsächlich auch einen Schlag an den Fall,
wie meine Mutter, und der andere ist einem im Autounfall verstorben.
Herr Schimmit, ich nehme an, dass Sie im Uhestand sind.
Richtig, genau.
Was haben Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich war schreiner.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand verheiratet?
Ich habe eine Frau, und wir haben zwei Kinder.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Haben Sie Stress in Ihrem Alltag, Herr Schimmit?
Gar nicht.
Ich bin ja im Uhestand.
Ich versuche, mein Leben zu genießen.
Aber immer wenn ich zu krank bin, dann ist das anstrengend für mich.
Herr Schimmit, ich habe keine Fragen mehr.
Haben wir alles besprochen, oder mögen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Was glauben Sie denn?
Warum werde ich so krank?
Warum sind Vitamine?
Woran liegt das denn?
Ich nehme schon Vitamin C ein, ich informiere mich aber,
ich verstehe nicht, warum das so oft so oft krank wäre.
Ja, das ist verständlich, dass Ihre Symptome in den Sorgen bereiten.
Aber es war gut, dass Sie sonst gekommen sind, Herr Schimmit.
Ich werde Sie jetzt noch Köpeli untersuchen, dann nehmen wir noch Blutab,
dann eine bildgebende Verfahrung wie Röntgen von Ihrem Brust.
Dann besprechen wir, was das Problem sein könnte, oder die Befunde.
Dann sehen wir, wie es weitergeht.
Geben Sie mir dann ein besseres Antibiotikum, oder was machen wir dann?
Je nach Ergebnisse können wir noch einmal denken, ob ich Ihnen eine neue Antibiotik gebe
oder ob Sie stationär bleiben sollten.
Ich dazu bleibe nicht.
Ich muss nach Hause, meine Frau versorgen.
Was geht? Ich kann nicht stationär bleiben.
Ich kann Sie nicht zwingen, im Krankenhaus zu bleiben.
Aber lassen Sie uns Untersuchung ergeben, ist aufwarten.
Okay.
Okay, bitte legen Sie Sie auf die Liege, ich würde Sie Köpeli untersuchen,
wenn Sie ein Verstanden sind.
Sehr gerne.
So, machen wir.
Arztgespräch, oder?
Wenn, keine Fragen mehr.
Gibt es Fragen von den Kollegen?
Bekommen Sie gute Luft?
Wenn ich mich belaste, nicht so gut.
Also beim Treppensteigen oder wenn ich einkaufe, dann habe ich schon Luftprobleme.
Ich habe auch keine dicken Beine oder so.
Danke.
Haben wir schon beantwortet, ist manchmal trocken der Husten,
manchmal mit Auswurf, manchmal auch blutig.
Okay, dann machen wir weiter.
Guten Tag Herr Oberrass.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient gesehen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Herzlich willkommen.
Ja, gerne.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Petalschmit.
Er ist 77 Jahre alt, 1,85 kg, 75 kg.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns, mit Zeit 4 bis 5 Monaten,
5 Jahre, 5 Jahre Husten vor.
Er gab an, dass bei Husten,
dass er manchmal Blut bemerkt hat,
besonders morgen auftreten.
Er hat eine Schmerzentwicklung,
beim Einatmen mit einer Schmerzintensität von 4, 10 Säne
und Belastungsabhängigdüstung.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen,
war der Patient Svajman,
Svajman bei seinem Hausarzt,
der im Svajman Antibiotiktherapie
verschrieben hat.
Jedoch ohne nennenswerte Linderung.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass bei Lobountersuchung
nur weißen Blutkörperchen erhöht sind.
Die Frage nach Limptonevergrößern,
Hautveränderung,
einen Unfall und ähnliche Vorherriebeschwerden
wurden verneint.
Die Vegetarineser,
nachschweiß oder hiperhydrosa,
inapetens mit Gewissabnahme
von etwa 5 Kilogramm innerhalb von 4 Monaten.
Ansonsten war die Vegetarineser unaufwählig.
Als Vorerkrankung
eine Diabetes-Mehl-Inzulichtige,
die Diabetes-Mehl-Inzulichtige seit 18 Jahren
und eine Arterelle Hypertone
seit ungefähr 37 Jahren bekannt.
Er spritzt in Zulin regelmäßig
mit 60 Milligramm Zweimal-Teilung,
5 Milligramm Amlodipin,
einmal Abends ein.
Vor 20 Jahren
wurde der Patient wegen einer Knoten
in ihrem Ellenbogen operiert.
Eine Laktose Intoleranz
ist bei ihm bekannt,
die sich mit Metorismus und Diare äußert.
Die Reise an einem Nese
ergab,
im Sommer in Ägypten
und in der Zeit,
dass er nicht gibt,
auch Corona,
seit 30 Jahren
eine Packung Zigaretten,
die 30 Teckers entspricht
und trinken selten
Flaschenwein monatlich.
Corona wurde verneid.
In der Familienanmese ist zu erwähnen,
dass seine Mutter
an einem Apoplex verstorben ist
und seine
Zweichwester,
oder er hat zwei Schwester,
eine von einem Apoplex verstorben.
Die andere ist bei einem Ottenfall verstorben.
Der Vater
ist auch verstorben.
Die Mutter war unbekannter.
Er ist beruflich,
er ist im Ruhestand,
er hat bevor als Schreiner gearbeitet.
Sozial, er ist verheiratet
und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Von der Symptomatik denke ich an eine bronchial Karsinom.
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen eine atypische Pynomonie,
eine bronchiektase in Betracht.
Kann er eine Tuberkulose haben?
Ja, überkulose.
Er war ja im Ausland gewesen.
Er hatte auch etwas anderes.
Er war im Obtusen, aber durch den Auslands an der Mese,
war er bei einem Hotel oder bei einem heimlichen.
Er hat sich eine Pilzinfektion zugenommen.
Man muss auf jeden Fall auch eine Infektion denken.
Aber die Arbeitsdiagnose am SRECHT bei Bäsentomatik mit Gewichtsverlust
und letztendlich auch hemoptysen und chronischem Husten länger als 4 Monate
sollte man auf jeden Fall bei bekannten Nikotinkonsum an
eine bronchial Karsinom denken.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch?
Als erstes würde ich den Patienten Körper unterdrücken.
Abkursch, ob es eine Auffälligkeit gibt.
Wenn man eine Röntgen-Torax anordnet,
dann sollte man sich die Röntgen-Torax anordnen.
Ob es Auffälligkeit gibt,
würde ich eine Bronchoscopy anordnen.
Sie nehmen den Patienten stationär auf.
Möchtest du den Patienten stationär bleiben?
Nein, er wollte nicht stationär bleiben.
Dann sollten Sie ihn überreden, dass er stationär bleibt
und ihm sagen, dass es eine ernsthafte Erkrankung sein könnte
und wir dies stationär überprüfen müssen.
Was machen Sie, wenn er nicht stationär bleibt?
Zuerst würde ich den Patienten über die mögliche,
möglichst schwer gerade Probleme wie Krebs abklären.
Wenn der Patienten 100% nicht bleiben wollte,
kann ich nicht machen,
nur eine zentrale Sette zu bekommen.
Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten?
Was empfehlen Sie?
Sagen Sie einfach Tschüss?
Nein.
Was wollen Sie dem Patienten machen?
Ich möchte über die Symptome informieren.
Diese Symptome könnten auf eine gerade schweren Krankheit
wie Krebs hinweisen.
Deswegen sollte der Patienten unbedingt weitere Untersuchungen
durchgeführt werden.
Er sollte auf jeden Fall weitere Untersuchungen bekommen.
Auch ambulant kann man ja auch ambulant machen.
Wenn der Patient sagt, ich bleibe auf keinen Fall hier,
dann sollte ich den Patienten auf eine andere Seite
auf eine andere Seite aufhören.
Ich muss meine Frau versorgen.
Sie sollten die Patienten ans Herz legen.
Bitte gehen Sie zu Ihrem Hausarzt.
Der soll eine Röntgen oder ein CT oder weitere Diagnostik einleiten.
Ich wollte nicht stationär bleiben,
weil ich meine Frau versorgen musste.
Aber ich soll die Untersuchungen bekommen.
Man kann das ja planen.
Man muss nicht stationär bleiben,
aber es wäre ratsam, dass der Patient stationär bleibt.
Sehr gut.
Wenn es eine Lungenkarcinum ist,
kann man eine Biopsy mit Bronchyskopie oder CT gesteuert machen.
Wenn es weißer Lateral oder außen liegt,
kann man auf CT gesteuert umtieren.
Dann wahrscheinlich Chemotherapie oder Operation.
Sehr gut.
Gibt es sonst Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
Haben wir alles richtig gemacht?
Haben wir alles falsch gemacht?
Haben wir Lungenfachärzte oder Torachs-Chirurgen?
Die uns weiter aufklären können?
Bei so einem Fall.
Wichtig ist mir, dass man an Lungenkarcinum denken muss.
Aber man muss mit Bedenken der Patienten
in einem anderen Land über 6 Monate machen.
Vielleicht hat er dort eine atypische Prämonie.
Das ist wahrscheinlich unwahrscheinlich.
Aber eine Tuberkulose kann er mitgenommen haben.
Eine Aspergillose oder eine andere Lungeninfekt.
Das kann auch sein.
Er hat gesagt, nach einem Antibiotikum wird es besser.
Dann wird es wieder schlecht.
Wenn keine weiteren Fragen sind,
Herr Abtola, ich denke, Sie haben alles gut gemacht.
Die Deutsch ist gut.
Ich habe mich gefragt und gestellt.
Viel Erfolg weiterhin.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Für Ausreisefragen.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Zeit?
Wir haben in den letzten 6 Monaten Fragen.
Oder im einen Jahr ist es wichtig?
Es kommt darauf an, was er hat.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel, es kommt auf die Erkrankungen.
Aber wichtig ist schon,
dass Sie den Patienten fragen, ob er in der letzten Zeit,
ich würde sagen, bis zu einem Jahr im Ausland war,
er ist nicht geimpft.
Er wollte keine Impfungen haben.
Aber wenn er zum Beispiel nicht einen Usp.
Er konnte auch eine Hepatitis haben.
Oder etwas anderes,
die er sehr schmär, spät zum Vorschein tritt.
Man sollte fragen, ob er im Ausland gewesen ist.
Wenn er sagt, ich war letztes Jahr in der Türkei,
in Spanien, in der USA,
sollte man das immer im Hinterkopf haben.
Manchmal machen die Patienten ja sehr außergewöhnliche Reisen.
Die fahren in den Dschungel.
Oder machen eine Trekking-Tour.
Oder sie kommen mit vielen Tieren in Kontakt.
Das sollte man immer im Hinterkopf haben.
COPD-Anfallen kann sein.
COPD kann sein, richtig.
Er wird mit sich eine COPD haben.
Das wird man als Diagnose mitwerten.
Weil er immer wieder Exzertsabationen hat.
Aber der Patient nimmt keine Narrative ein.
Kein Cortison.
Daher kann die COPD wahrscheinlich nicht sofort geschritten sein.
Aber es kann auch die erste Diagnose einer COPD sein.
Mit Lungenemphysim, mit Bronchiaktasin.
Was spricht er hier mit Pesium-Thematik für eine Lungenkarsinum?
Kann ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Wenn wir eine Reise an einem Nase machen,
wie fragt man die COPD-Anfragen?
Wie fragt man die Reise?
Er hat gesagt, in der Äquipe.
Sollen wir fragen, wo Sie in der Äquipe übernachten?
Oder wie viele Tagen Sie da geblieben?
Oder kontaktieren Sie andere Menschen?
Sie haben gesagt, viele Äquipe,
die ärzte Diagnose, sollen wir fragen oder nicht?
Ich würde fragen, waren Sie da im Hotel?
Haben Sie Hotelurlaub gemacht?
Oder waren Sie bei Einheimischen?
Er hat mich nach Hause eingeladen.
Wir waren zwei Wochen zu Hause mit Freunden.
Wir waren draußen im Restaurant gegessen.
Wir waren in der Wüste.
Ich würde fragen, ja.
Waren Sie im Hotel?
Oder waren Sie mit dem Patientenkontakt?
Die auch krank waren?
In dieser Konstellation, ja.
Noch eine andere Frage.
Wenn wir denken, die Patient hat eine Krebs,
Buracian-Karsinoma.
Sollen wir unkollegierkonsult antworten?
Nein, das müssen Sie nicht sofort machen.
Aber Sie können den Patienten,
ich weiß nicht, welche Station Sie arbeiten,
wenn Sie eine Notaufnahme sind,
können Sie dafür sorgen,
dass der Patient auf eine unkologische Station kommt.
Aber wenn Sie schon, Sie sehen ja im Röntgen,
wenn Sie eine Röntgen oder einen CT machen,
bringen Sie den Verdacht auf Lungenkarsinom.
Dann sollten Sie sich automatisch die Kollegen
von der Onkologie mit einschalten.
Im besten Falle verlangen Sie den Patienten
direkt auf eine unkologische Station.
Vielen Dank.
Wir besorgen Fragen, Anreize,
haben wir etwas vergessen.
Dann wünsche ich jedem einen schönen Sonntag.
Danke.
Alles Gute.